[Music]
well hello everyone this is ifran syed
from team simply learn
today i'm going to talk about microsoft
excel tutorial in this
tutorial we will be talking about macros
used in excel
and also the visual basic application
programming
for macros so what is excel macro you do
certain daily tasks and daily reports or
monthly reports that you generate
and you use data from your excel and you
scrub data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your excel
you remove certain columns you add
certain things and you
change certain values and these are the
things that you do
an n number of times on an excel
and this can all be done by simple
automated wave which is macros
so what it does is it is a set of tasks
that you can execute as many number of
times as you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record
all your mouse clicks and keystrokes
basically
if for example you have your monthly
accounts report
that is there and it comes every day and
you have to
put it and extract certain data and
remove certain
columns that you do every time that you
open that sheet
for instance you remove that column i
which has the
absolute values of of your accounts or
the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report
and then you format it in a proper way
and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple running script called macros
so what you do is you record those
mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for
it save it and next time tomorrow when
you come you just
run that macros and this will do
everything for you
and you do not have to do that same
tedious task every day
so this is basically a set of code
or a task that you can execute and
automate
and which can be done a number of times
so
it makes your life easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros
in your excel it's a simple uh
tab that you need to add in the ribbon
section which i'll be showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to files
go to and then you need to customize the
ribbon click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here
it should be activated so you just need
to select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it over
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way
right click on any of the tabs on the
ribbon
customize ribbon and you can add
or remove your macros from here
so this is two ways that you need to
that you can activate
your macros so how you record a macro is
the next
thing so here i have a work orders
sheet that i receive every day or one of
you
will receive every day and how you
record a macro you
have certain set of tasks that you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record
macro button it will start recording
your key strokes on the mouse
mouse clicks and you can save that and
run it as a script
in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that i have and
we'll try to run a macros on this
and see what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way i need to
go to the developer tab and
start recording a macro so when i click
a record macro it
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
keystrokes
so in this sheet i have to you know
remove some columns and the columns that
are obsolete and the data that looks
weird here should be removed and all
what i need
is the work order number the district
and the tactician name
and the kind of service that we provide
and
the requested workday the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do
it every day when i receive the sheet
and i have to
make these changes and send it across to
the
accounts team so what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro so
i go to let's see how it records the
macro
i click record macro i save it as
work order accounts
and i'll add a little description like
work order for
account
first click ok
and see what i do is basically i
add the borders first
so that the data looks proper and then i
do not
want this column i delete it i do not
want the number of technicians that are
there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account
and what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the fmst
i do not want any of these obsolete data
so i just delete this okay
and then i just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
i make sure this doesn't have any border
and that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording
so now i have the macro save and
when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet
so i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be changed or
formatted and send it across
so i simply go the next morning and go
to the developer tab
and go to the macro and i have this
macro save which we ran
the just now and i simple with a single
click
i will be able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready
and is in a proper format that is
required and it can be sent across so
here as we see it is done in a single
click
by running a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button
by adding a button so what you have to
do
is go to the developer tab and in the
control section
you will see the insert option when you
click on the insert drop down you will
see
a form controls and you can say select a
button
and here i select a button and the mouse
changes to across and you can add
your macro and assign it so as we have
saved it work order accounts as a macro
and when i just assign that macro to
this button
i can edit the text by
making this work order
account just to make it simple okay
and now if you see if i just click this
button
it will run the macro and format our
sheet
so this is how we run the macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros
in instead of the developer tab and you
go to the view button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your macro
so when i click view macros it will show
you what are the macros that i have
and that i can run and you can simply
run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as
well instead of from the developer tab
if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab okay
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro
you have to use a simple application in
excel which is the vba visual basic
application
to edit your macro you go to the
developer tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window like this
and you will see the module that you
have been working on
and you can edit the macro here
so as we see if you go back to the
excel we see that our sheet we have been
working
on the sheet and it has the column still
k
and the actual sheet is this so if i go
to the visual basic
editor and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are
existing from the column m
and i just delete that and i click
run
i go back to my sheet and you see
these changes are not there okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the
vba so here we are
what is vba visual basic application
it is basically a visual basic
application
language that is used for macros
in excel so what it basically does
visual basic for application is a
programming language of excel
that helps you automate tasks by writing
macros
we have seen how we use macros how it
simplifies our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro now to
help us you know write these macros and
help us
get the best use of our abilities
to ease our work and automate our task
we use vba so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba
and why we prefer vba in macros for
excel so basically it
is a very simple language it saves time
in performing tedious tasks you have
number of tasks that you do every day as
we have seen in the previous
section how we uh you can simplify your
daily task by just running a simple
macro
and this vba helps us in performing
those steps
in a very simple manner another thing is
it supports english like statements
there are multiple statements that you
can
use and which are very basic english
language statements
and this can help us or it is very easy
to program
or code or edit these commands you can
select a range you can it is like
if an else statement and things like
that
we'll look into those in details in the
next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of
excel by allowing you to make excel
behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of
rows or columns or selecting a set of
cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be
edited and executed by using vba
we will look into those in detail now
what is the vba
editor interface this is particularly
uh an interface which you will have uh
look in detail where where you can edit
your commands or your code for your
excel
now how this is achieved we will see
it here now these are the this is
basically the vba editor interface
where you can see the uh this is the
toolbar section where it shows
all the options where in undo or save
or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section
of the vba editor interface the next
thing is the menu bar menu bar as we all
know
it is simply it shows you the menu
wherein you have all the
options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing
all these things fall under menu bar the
next thing
is the vba code window baby code window
as it says
is the code window where your actual
code resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and
select the different range of functions
that you can perform
and this is basically the bdb vba code
window
where you edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project explorer
project explorer is simply like a
windows explorer but
this is in particular is specific to
your
vba wherein it shows the different
options that are there the excel sheets
or the worksheets that you're working on
or the modules that you have saved and
so on
basically it is an explorer for your vba
like a windows explorer which is for the
file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows
shows you the properties of the
worksheet that you're working on
for instance here we are working on the
sheet 2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left
whether it is enabled or not the name of
the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing
is the immediate window and the
watch window now what is the immediate
window
immediate window is basically a tool
or a window wherein you can run and
execute
simple lines of codes individual excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines which is very
useful and handy when you are writing
and debugging codes the output if the
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window
whereas watch window watch window is
similar to it
but it displays the value of the watch
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we
are debugging the vba code adding a
watch
is a great utility and we will see uh
the use the advantages of having a watch
window
in your vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it
in detail in the coming section now we
continue our topic for
visual basic per application for macros
and
uh i'm going to show you how to you know
run some codes and run
some macros and codes and perform some
simple
to complex tasks using the vba for
macros
so there are two ways to open the visual
basic application
and the first thing is you can run alt
f11 click on the sheet and then
just press and it will open the
um visual basic for application window
or alternatively you can just go and
click on the visual basic and it will
open the
sheet value i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window
and this is the project explorer
and this is the immediate window i will
you can run some
testing course immediately it will show
you the output
so here we see the project explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to
record a macro and see how the code
develops okay
so i just go here and click record
macro and i save it
as the format
and columns
okay this quickbook and i just saved it
click okay
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is as
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here okay
i do not need this i delete this
either a weight i want this i want the
amount of payment
parts cost labor hours i do not want
this
number of technicians forget it okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need
i don't need this i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then i want to change the format i
mean the hot
so i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
okay go back to my
developer tab click stop recording
it is saved okay
now i go back to my code
and see the macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
in detail what it looks like so we see
the
code what it's doing and what the macro
run has generated the code so we see
we have basically the name of the macro
is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting the columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the
e column that we have selected and then
again
so on and the next thing is the font
selection that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically a basic vba code so
it starts with the sub and it should end
with
end sub so this is the code or a format
of the vba code that it looks like
and we'll try to do some basic functions
with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and i'll try to explain
some basic functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the task that we with vba
so as we see this is a blank sheet and i
have selected a new module for it
so here i uh start the code and i just
says it starts with sub
and i am specifying the
module name as number so i'll just try
to
make it quite simple and you know
so we as soon as we enter the sub it
sends with the end sub and so this is
the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here
and this is the name of the code or the
macro
now uh i'll explain it further about the
dim statement why is it used and what
does it use for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare
variables in the vba so here i am trying
to
specify a variable called
x and how i'm going to do it i will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything
so here in this example i'll put it as
an integer or a number
okay and as i put as it populates
the prompt so i select integer and for
example i
select the number to be 500
okay and here i'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value
of 500 with dim keyword
so where exactly i want to put this
you will see it when you execute the
code okay
range i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the
value of x as and i close the bracket
and what should be the value
we will value should be x
so now as i click run serve
or you can do it with the by running the
alt
f5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the excel sheet
it
executes the value of the cell b5 to be
500 so
this is one simple function that you can
do with the
dimension keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed
we proceed further with certain more
examples some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or something else
okay now i'm going to show you what
dim can be executed used as to set
variables team can be
used as a double
when double is basically a longer form
of
single variable it usually takes more
space but uses
uh needs more larger numbers okay and
then you can
set double and i just
don't specify it and we can use state
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again
string so what string does if you use
string
it stores the text it can contain
numbers it will
have some text as calculations or
anything can be performed
so these are the basic thing that i will
cover
and you can also use different
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
so in the next example i'll try to set
or
use a string value for it and
i put it as a string so string
value this is my name
so as soon as i hit enter it ends with
the answer prompt and now i can
give my code so i put it as dim book
as string
okay now i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to
one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and i select country
and in country i select mark
[Music]
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country at so i have to
specify
a range and as soon as i hit it goes
and i have to specify the
the cell here so here i put it as
g and 4
okay so i close it
and i put a value to it what value i am
going to assign
it is a country okay
now i'll try to run this code by simply
and see g4 the name
populates as a country here so this
is a dim keyword you being used as a
string
in our vba code so
uh we can also use uh vba to
you know pop up a message or an alert or
a kind of a button
or a message pop-up pops up when you
execute this code so this basically can
be uh
executed using uh the
code here which i'm going to put and we
use the
okay let's give it a value
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword i'm going to use
the
keyword as double okay y double
is used is basically uh it gives a
longer
it can be used for a longer form of
single variable takes
it usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now i'm going to pop up a message in
this which says
value of a is so and so so i'm going to
give value of
a as 2 5 0
okay and how i it pops up a message
okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean uh it will
prompt you
to enter the value what kind of uh
button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter already so here i'm going to
write a code which you know which gives
a pop-up message a message box saying
that the value of a
is so and so
the value of a i'm going to put it in
percent code so it actually takes the
value of a okay now
that's it and let's try to run this and
you will see a message bob
popping message box popping up okay
so the value of the message box pops up
saying the value of a is 250 so
in the next example i am going to write
a code wherein you know
you can give a value or a string you can
assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when
you have some you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay
so this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say it as
fun with some procedures
this is the name and again
so here i am going to i'm going to give
a user input and it will be as
a string okay you can give anywhere i
mean any string or
any statement what my user input will be
i will define it here
because this
is the report
for vba let's make it simple
okay and where i'm going to put it
is in the active cell or the cell
that i have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
i have defined user input as this is a
report for vba so
this cell turns into you this is a
report for vba
i run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba for this
as we have seen before we have used
message box now i'm going to use the
same message box
to display my name or you can
use it to display your name so let's see
how it goes
i'm going to name it as name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name
is
and we'll try to run it
see here so it pops up a message
saying that my name isn't fun so this is
a message box that you can display
and i can do anything with this
this is
okay i run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know
when you open an excel sheet or try to
run
a workshop or a report
and it pops up a message customary
welcome messages that you can
customize or you know define a
report or kind of data in it and this
can be
used using run using the message box
and now i have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell
so here it is i put the sub
okay number
and it will again populate a message
box which will set it to
the the entered
[Music]
value is and it should tell me
which or i specify which cell
it is that we are going to find the
value of
okay so i give a range
of i have to give it in
codes i'm going to
go to complete it and it should tell me
the
value of the number that is present in
the cell
a1 okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how
we can use excel to determine or show or
populate a message box which will give
us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a 4 as well
and try to run it and it will give me
the number
so this is simple way of you know
populating a
message box which will tell us the value
of
it uh let me show you one more simple
example where in a message
box pops up on a welcome message that
can be pop
set when you open the excel or
worksheet so so let's
[Music]
name it as auto open
and then again message box
i want it to populate and what does it
say
i put it in quotes welcome
to our worksheet
of workshop
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying welcome
to a workshop
so these are the one more this is one
more way where you can you know run a
code or
to simple welcome message on excel
next i'm going to show you a code
wherein you can
give a value or assign a value to a
particular cell
by simple curve
so we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell where
the value will be given to the
cell now i'm going to give it as v5
okay to put it as codes close the
parenthesis
what is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 five zero okay so now
with this code i mean i'm going to
assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to p10
okay so this is how you can assign a
value to a particular
cell now i can run
the same thing and give a range of cells
i mean
let me make it very simple here
i give it as b1
through b
5 as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here i'm going i'm specifying the
range
to be b1 through b5 so it is doing it
for the whole
range okay and
then i can give a another set of range
here
like let me specify it
range to be
c one
i have to give it a course it will give
me an error
c1 colon c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so
the next one will be d1 to
d4 and then i close the codes
close the parenthesis what is the value
that i give
is let's say
2 3 0
and i try to run it so
it gives the value of c1 through c4
and d1 through d4 as 230 as we specified
in the code so this is one of one more
example where
you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells
and with the vba
one more thing i can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple
just specify the cells like
six comma seven
okay and i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it value equals
10. let's see
see here it assigns the value to that
particular
cell that we have specified row 6
and columns okay
so this is one more example wherein you
can
assign values to particular cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario where
you need to select a range of cells
in the sheet so this can also be done
this task can also be performed using
vba
so i will show you how
this is our let's say select a
range okay and
and i am going to set a dim variable as
example okay let's say it has example
and
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells okay now i'm going to set the
variable as
set example where i am going to define
the
range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a one
two
okay this will be the selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set a
value example
i'm going to give it a value of 256.
so let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value with this function
so this makes it quite simple and this
will be used in a regular
daily task wherein you know there is
there will be a scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it
with a click of a button with the vpn
now i can simply tweak this with you
know
by just selecting it so there is
i'll remove this and
instead of assigning a value i'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it
okay and then you see it becomes easier
for you to copy paste and do some
functions
so you can select this and you can
assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or
cells with these codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet and i
can do this
with the setup another set of commands
so
i will show you how so here let's
say you know we said the same thing and
we specify the
worksheets okay worksheets
i want it in sheet two okay so i just
put it as g2
and i activate it basically
activating it and now i'm going to
specify the worksheet
to and what is the range that i'm going
to select
the same thing okay the range will be
a1 to
d5
okay what i'm going to do i'm going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay so here i am selecting the
worksheet too and i'm activating it and
i'm
going to assign range and i'm going to
select it so
i can just copy the same or select the
same set of
cells in the next sheet okay now
when there will be uh as i said there
will be
you know by requirement where you need
to copy some cell contents and paste it
to another location
so how you do that it's again a simple
code that you can write and let's say
let's say it has a copy
and paste i'm just making it simple by
giving something that we can
understand and relate
[Music]
copy paste
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to select
this range and i'm going to copy it
and paste it somewhere here okay so
let me just remove this and
i'll show you first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy
the cells okay so let's say it is again
a1
it should be in codes
[Music]
okay then what i'm going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have should
what should be the function and i am
going to specify the selection
and the function should be copying it
okay so i just said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to paste this selection
and you can just mention the column here
let's say g
10 okay
and close it i'm going to
select it and then where i'm going to
paste it i can do it in this sheet
okay active sheet
and paste it so we are
selecting a range of cells selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then paste it
quite simple let's see
okay and
you can just change it so it is visible
on this
g5
okay so this makes uh
quite easy and you can run it
uh the next scenario will be like when
you
need to get the count of the number of
cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say the sub b
count cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say i'm going to set an
example
for this and what we're going to do is
we are going to specify a range first
okay we will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically
so i'm going to set a variable as a
range and
then what we are going to do is
example and we
specify the range can specify the range
or your selection where you count the
where you need the count of the
number of cells so a1
d5 codes now
how you want the output you want it you
want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and what should it give you
will give you the count of the variable
that is the
variable is here is examples okay
so it will count the number of cells in
this
area
okay uh let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the
number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of count in this
20
okay now let's see i want to
six so it gives you the selection so
it's quite simple it will be very useful
in our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells
so this is one way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or to count the number of rows or
columns so it's again very simple
i just need to do some changes here i
have to set the
column count
so if i want to calculate the
number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here see it gives
there are five columns okay one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here
if i change it to it should give me
four followers okay similarly you can
count the
number of rows here
just change it to rows
see says six rows are there
okay should give me
see so this way you can calculate the
number of
count the number of cells number of
columns number of
rows with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement
if statement is one of the most widely
used
statement and whoever is in programming
i'm very much familiar with this
function so what it does is we specify a
condition
if a condition is met then the out
should output should be
such and such we can specify the
condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
space i mean if it is achieved then you
will have to specify the
output as well so this can be achieved
with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because
it is it understand the basic english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how so the syntax can
be like this
if suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met then
the result you specify the condition and
the result
okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the else or
else condition where you know you
specify the condition 2
then the result should be
this so
here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify this and if it is there
then result will be this if it is this
condition
and then the result will be something
else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or marks and
you have to select the result you can't
do this
manually entering so just you can write
a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay
and i specify as
if statement
okay now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string pass
or fail
so i specify this okay dim
score i specify it as
integer okay and then
there's another variable that i have to
set the result
as string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
the
it's in my cell a1
okay i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay sorry
should be a dot
okay and then i'm specifying a condition
here
if score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions then
the result result is another variable
that i have said
result what it should be it should be in
quotes
pass okay
so if this condition is met then the
result will be
this okay and now where i want to
specify my
result i should give a range for that as
well so i give it in the next column
or any one
this is the basic uh example
value should be the result
okay let's see
see says pass
change it to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
75 let's see how it runs
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables
the score and the result and then you
are giving a value for it
and you are specifying the condition if
the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition
and see so here again we'll use two
variables that is the score
as integer and the result as a string
and let's uh stick to the same values
and now i'm going to specify it
and if the score is greater than 60
then the result so the result will be
pass as it is before and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay and now i have to
put it to the end if statement i have to
specify the answer and the result will
be again
in the value i mean the range will be b1
so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is
fail
okay this pass let's see
40.
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving at a range and we
are specifying one
condition if this condition is met the
result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use or we
are going to discuss
is the loop statement that is the for
loop statement
and why we use it there are there are
situations in
uh tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times these are basically
executed sequentially it means one after
another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so and then the next and so
on so
these loop statements allow us to
execute a statement
or a group of statements multiple number
of times many number of times
and this happens only when the first
task or the first
task is done and it executes that and it
goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example
of the for loop statement
so let's see how it works
and i'm going to set up a
loop statement okay again the i'm going
to make it as loop 1
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay
for x equals to 1 2
three four okay let's see and
i'm going to specify the range
range as so what i'm going to do is
basically i'm going to fill the
column a from 1 to 24
with some value 1 from 1 to 24 with the
values of
1 through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a range
and how it ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
so i'll explain you how
so we are setting up a loop we are
setting up an integer a variable
x as integer and we are setting the
value of
x to be 1 to 24 so here
for 1 it executes the first thing is it
it takes
x as 1 and it fills in
a1 and then the next value of x will be
2 and it goes to a2 and fills the value
as 2. so
just let's try to execute this and you
will see the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the
number of values and the variable as x
and the number of values is going to be
24 okay
so this is one basic example of a for
loop statement
uh now let's do some more uh addition to
this
uh example by you know
executing another set of for loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the
color code advance in the column b so
how we do it it's a basic simple example
that i'm going to take
and again what i'm going to do is i will
have this values here
and i'm going to color code the b
column with certain color index for each
number there will be a different color
so let's see and
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we are going to
select it and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and it should color the interior
with what
with the color index okay
and the value of x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what pattern
it will take for the box to be colored
and i'm going to put it as a
solid it will fill the whole thing with
the
solid and then i just execute it
see it takes this
color b and let's code it like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
you can perform tasks we can perform
with the
vba and this can be
found in detail next versus advanced
courses
so thank you so much and for more
information you can visit our website
www.simplylearn.com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here